hi thank you for coming today I'm glad
we're doing food violations after lunch
instead of before so I don't turn anyone
stomach so my objective here today is
kind of twofold I worked on this project
and I'm presenting it as that project
but also I'm a novice data science
practitioner and so I'm presenting this
project as also a way to show other
novice data scientist science
practitioners a framework for
approaching these problems so in in that
respect how many people here have worked
on one data science project how many
people have worked on at least three
data science projects how many people
have worked on five or more data science
projects okay you guys are going to
answer all my questions at the end then
so I am a recovering consultant I like
to say I worked in computer forensics
and electronic discovery for a long
number of years and decided about a year
ago to make a career switch into data
science I have been using Python for
about a year I did do an undergrad in
computer science but didn't have much
call for programming after school so I'm
just getting back into it I am currently
the teaching assistant at Georgetown in
the School of Continuing Studies in the
data science program I've also completed
a data science boot camp and I'm
affiliated with district data labs where
I'm working in the research lab on
entity resolution this term I also do
not have a PhD which is I feel kind of
makes me an outlier and some of these
things because it's like every other
person you talked to has a PhD or is
going for their PhD or coming from a
different discipline with a PhD to do
this type of work so I am definitely
here in front of you as a novice to help
facilitate other novices launching into
data science so then why am I here if I
don't have any of those big credentials
backing me up well because I wrote the
proposal obviously but I wrote the
proposal because I do work with a
community of people who are very
supportive I started working in
switching the data science about the
time when it women did a scientist DC
started so I had that community
initially
through my work at Georgetown I met a
lot of the people from district data
labs and have built up that community
too so even though I have a limited
experience I want to show other people
out there with limited experience that
there is still a lot that you can do and
then this project so this project I
worked on as a capstone for my boot camp
program i worked with one other person
in my cohort to complete it i got the
idea for the project by networking
through code for DC if anybody's
familiar with open data nation they've
worked on replicating this project quite
a bit so the the director of opened a
donation worked with me to help give me
some guidance and how to do this so that
the idea of the project is to replicate
a Food Inspection forecasting system
that Chicago created about two years ago
and made open source their project was
in arm they had the involvement of the
city when they worked on it open data
nation then replicated it for Montgomery
County again with the involvement of the
local government entities this project
that I'm doing uses that as a launching
point and then works in Python also it's
a prototype at this point we didn't have
any involvement from the city of DC on
working on it so there's a lot of domain
expertise I think that they could
probably bring to the table that we
don't have at this point so in
approaching the problem I started at the
data science pipeline if you've been
working in data science this is probably
very familiar to you you get some data
you ingest it you wrangle it you do some
computations visualizations boom you
have a report but in reality things end
up more like this you have a report it
might not be what you want you start
over looking at your data you get to
some wrangling and realize you might
have to ingest some other things and you
go through the program the pipeline
again but first of course we need to
start with our question what question do
we want the data ant to answer so here
we have our classic hypothesis so the
hypothesis in this case is that we can
use machine learning to predict when a
critical violation is likely to occur at
a restaurant and prior to prioritize
those inspections
so the violations can be caught sooner
and mitigate foodborne illness outbreaks
and most effectively deploy limited
resources that government entities have
in DC there's about twenty two
inspectors in the Department of Health
and there's over 5500 food
establishments that they keep track of
at this point because I have not worked
with them I don't know what their
prioritization scheme is typically from
what we know is if a restaurant is
assigned a higher risk category it gets
inspected more often and there's some
kind of scheduling to it this project I
should also say work strictly with
routine inspections this does not work
with inspections that were predicated by
complaints or any of the other numerous
things that that trigger a DC
inspections such as a change of
ownership construction your
establishment or anything along those
lines so where do we start with what the
data of course so we have three things
we need to look at an instance which is
the thing that we are looking at
typically it's a noun of some sort it
has a lot of features which is the data
that describes it and then a prediction
so what's our outcome in this case the
instance the instance is a restaurant
inspection it has a lot of features in
and of itself so when you have a
restaurant inspection you know what kind
of violations there are you know where
the establishment was you know who
inspected it which can be a very
important predictor of outcome but
there's also a lot of things that go
into the environment surrounding a
restaurant inspection so for example is
there a lot of crime in that area or non
emergency service requests which might
indicate a neighborhood is deteriorating
or has infrastructure issues what was
the weather like prior to that
inspection Chicago found that heat
definitely increases the chance of the
critical violation because your
refrigeration units and things like that
start working a lot harder has there
been a change in the frequency people
start reporting Yelp reviews or has
their rating on yelp changed does the
building have aged issues does this
establishment serve alcohol so based on
prior domain expertise in this situation
we know there's a lot of things that can
affect what else might predict the
outcome so we then go and look at what
data we can ingest from the situation
when I started this project I had a
identified data set that had been
compiled by a third party unfortunately
initial exploration of the data set
showed that it was not updating anymore
so the data was that a date and I had to
make a decision do I go ahead and scrape
all the data myself or do I work with
the old data set um what I ended up
doing at the time because it sounded
like fun what scraping the data here is
an example of what an inspection page on
the Department of Health work website
looks like DC makes this data available
but I don't think i would call it open
they're currently hosting it in a third
party system that doesn't have a
public-facing api for pulling in any of
the information talking to some of my
code for DC contacts I ended up with a
script to start pulling the information
in it was my first time deploying a red
scraper so of course I got blocked
eventually but not after I scraped all
the inspection search results so I had a
list of all the inspections and links to
them as well I was able at that point
then to to employ different technology
like selenium to download pages locally
for scraping later Yelp was a big source
of data and because i was working in
conjunction with a local company that
was interested in prototyping it they
wanted yelp data in it so I then had to
go look at yelp and see how to pull this
type of data from Yelp I don't know if
anybody's worked with the LPI Yelp API
it's great if you know the businesses ID
but if you have to use the API to get
business ideas for that data it can be
very cumbersome so you have the option
of using a phone API or a general search
api that's going to return a bunch of
results and the results are prioritized
in a weird way so even if you have a
matching name and address it's not
necessarily going to be the first result
you get back from their API
so as one of the points to work on in
the future if you're a novice in the
situation I had to make some decisions
so I had a deadline I needed to do there
is code for doing this with are based on
the previous projects that we're done
but I was required to do this in Python
for my project so I went ahead and
started pulling that information and it
turns out the information I had to build
out the yelp crosswalk was not the best
either so I have since gone back to look
at that and start building it out more
on as a part-time project so in addition
to scraping and the elbe api google
places API was also useful for pulling
in phone numbers to then use with Yelp
for inspection reports that didn't have
them and the forecast io API was very
useful for pulling in weather
information and then see click fix it
has DC data which has information on to
infrastructure problems reported through
SeeClickFix but unfortunately it's not a
huge historical download of DC 311 data
so next on to wrangling I had CSV from
the city's I pulled some of my API
returns into [ __ ] to see how that
worked because I was a student at the
time I was doing this and it seems like
a good exercise and trying things out I
used pandas to clean my data and also
create a bunch of tables that I could
load into sequel light to start matching
my disparate data sets up at this time
too i had another nice little road bump
all the features i wanted to use weren't
available DC has open data through dcra
on things like business / it permits and
they have a bruh data available so you
have liquor permit information but they
don't have an easy way to
cross-reference them so it's not an easy
name match problem where you can say
this molly malone's on h street that has
a different address that Miss Molly
Malone's on H Street is an easy match
and I can match them up in sequel it
does require a lot more human
intervention so I had to leave that data
out at
at the time I worked on the project but
there were other features to look at so
I also did some feature engineering
based on the information I had so if you
have crime reports for an area the most
useful way I found to use them was to
look in a half-mile radius of the
location and add up the crime reports
for the three days prior to the
inspection weather was also the average
high temperature for three days before
so using Python I was able to write
scripts that did a lot of this was word
that wouldn't show up very well um so
eighty percent of my time led me to this
huge data set with these instances that
is not all the categories I had
available to me because I also used the
Yelp category for a restaurant one thing
found predictive in Montgomery County
was sometimes the category of a
restaurant could be predictive on
whether or not they were likely to have
violations um luckily eighty percent of
data science is ingestion and wrangling
because that's eighty percent I enjoy
the most so once we got all this data
together next question became which
model do a try well if you're new to
this why not try all of them because I
kit learned makes it really easy for you
to do that I started out without using a
pipeline on this project pipelines kind
of clicked for me a little bit later so
the first try we went through and ran a
whole bunch of models and looked at our
output scores later went back in and
looked at building a pipeline to do a
little bit more uniform feature
selection so i did use custom
transformers in my pipeline if you are
new to python and new to data science
object oriented programming is
definitely useful for cases like this I
think my my moment on understanding how
powerful pipelines could be worse when I
was able to incorporate some object
oriented programming so here we have a
pipeline that goes through and takes a
certain set of features and process them
what standard scalar it takes another
set of features and uses
one hot encoder and then has some other
features that don't get any encoding at
all I built two different pipeline
models 12 you select from model to do
some feature selection and one without
and this comes the fun part this is my
best visualization I'm sorry I am not
paying into the visualizations so after
all that work the best I could do was
coin flip my model at this time is no
better than a coin flip on the test data
or the training data it was definitely a
little bit better there was the area
under the ROC curve was point 56 on some
of the other tests we tried we got some
better scores so here comes a lot of the
problems in doing a project like this
without domain expertise or buy-in from
the people you're doing it for one of
the very early things who noticed with
the project is that we had a huge class
imbalance issue there's a talk on class
imbalance this weekend that i will be
going to because of this only six
percent of our restaurants never had a
critical violation a six percent of our
restaurant inspection reports never
showed a critical violation based on
prior work that had been done it's known
that generally in a pass/fail situation
twenty to thirty percent of the
restaurants will fail and the rest will
pass so that definitely did not help the
situation basically we end up always
predicting a critical violation at this
point if we start balancing it out a
little bit and hit like a 75 25 split we
can say seventy five percent of the
restaurants have less than four
violations where twenty-five percent
have four or more and we get slightly
better scores working on that so after
all that it was not lost though because
one of the things you can do with your
model is have it put confident scores on
the predictions so using out a sample
data and the confidence score is
predicted by the model we can
reprioritize the order in which
restaurant inspections took place so at
a three-month out-of-sample data
population we knew the order the city
had inspected those restaurants in and
what the results were it when we put
them through the model we said okay what
is the confidence
score on your prediction for this
inspection and reordered based on the
highest confidence that situation got us
eleven percent more violations about ten
days sooner so even though the models
aren't fabulous yet there is still value
to be gained out of this so now what now
I get to make some lemonade out of my
lemons building a better data set more
data is definitely better data using the
presumption that we were going in that
we had to match up Yelp data with our
instance we had a data set of about
1,400 samples which is okay but isn't
the best it could be better so now the
follow-on work is to hook those up with
Yelp a little bit better by manually
creating the crosswalk between
restaurant names in DC and what their
yelp idea is also to to go back to the
old data set that i didn't use in the
first place and get more historical data
in some cases we only had two or three
rest inspection reports for a restaurant
which isn't a very deep history to build
a model off of and then get more input
the DC Department of Health website
talks about different violations but
doesn't necessarily spell out what is a
critical violation versa non critical
violation or how many critical
violations is considered a failure or
not failure and we had to do some work
on figuring that out on our own so what
I'm here to tell you if you're new to
this poor scores don't always mean
failure they're just a starting point it
can be a little discouraging as a new
data scientist to come to some of these
talks and hear everybody talk about how
things eat how easy things are all the
time but data science is hard you you
need to have data you need to understand
what your data can do you need to
understand what you can do to make your
data better and I apparently talk a lot
faster when I'm presenting than I do at
home when I'm giving this talk to my
cats so we have more time than
anticipated for questions
yes sure so um the question was where is
the code my github user name is right
here if you go on there there is ND one
on github there is a repository there
and there is also in the documentation
there a link to Chicago's original
project on what they did so if you are
an hour person I won't hold it against
you you can talk to me if your PI
curious and we'll work that out but that
the data is there to to work on it in
our as well so you could also just take
a data set that conforms to what Chicago
did and kind of run through that as is
right so so this is the psychic learn
pipeline model which lets you basically
build out a set of operations to perform
on your data so it eliminates the
variability that you might have if you
are working with something like get
dummies and pandas to to blow out some
of your variables it will make sure that
things get processed the same way each
time you run through the data what this
one does first is a feature union which
goes through and takes a set of columns
that I've defined and puts them through
the different encoding methods so we
have standard scalar to to get our data
more uniform we have one hot encoder
which deals with the yelp categories and
making them sort of dummy variables like
you would do in panda so if a restaurant
can have more than one category on Yelp
it can be American infusion so you would
have a whole bunch of features now that
say American fusion and one or zero to
indicate whether that's there or not on
it this pipeline
uses a select from model for feature
selection too so what that allows you to
do is use any of the scikit-learn
estimators that have certain
characteristics to look at reducing your
feature set once the Yelp theta
categories get added into this feature
set it expands out to over 200 features
which is a little lot a bit much to deal
with and some features are of course
more predictive than others and then it
takes that final output data set and
runs it through the estimator to try
this out so using this kind of setup you
can then just write a Python script that
calls your function and passes these
select for model and model estimator
items as variables so you can try
comment like tens of combinations in a
short amount of time with very little
work so this was built out as a function
in Python and then it's just a one line
here we go call it from there you can
take your scores back to and compile
them to a data frame that you can use
for comparison purposes so you can look
at how each models f1 score is and
precision accuracy and area under the
curve to compare your information the
estimators are I used were all
classifiers Chicago originally ran this
project as a linear regression so
they're actually in their case
predicting the probability of a
violation where this model that I put
together is predicting a yes or no
sure so what would what would did on
this project when we built the data out
is we came up with our complete data set
and then took the last three full months
of data we had and set that aside so the
model was only trained on the data minus
those three months when we have the
model built we put those three months in
and ran them through and output a
confidence interval on the
classification so there was a
classification yes it would or no it
wouldn't have a critical violation and
then the models score of confidence in
that prediction we then rearranged the
order of the inspection so if these five
restaurants had a higher probability
confidence interval than these five
restaurants they would be inspected
first by reordering that then you can
look at how quickly you can find
violations since we knew what the
violations were we could then do a
comparison on that point so I'm not sure
how DC picks through the routine
inspections they only seem to do about
ten a week on average based on the three
year historical data on the Department
of Health website for items they
categorize as a restaurant verse like a
cafeteria or a deli or bakery so from
there we can then say okay if they're
doing about ten a week so we can say two
inspections a day so these two
inspections would happen first in these
two inspections would happen next and
and see what the difference is between
the two models yes
sure so um we actually tried modeling
the data in a few different ways so the
first round that we went through for the
capstone project deadline was taking the
data and reconfiguring what was a pass
on what was a fail so instead of saying
yes this restaurant would have a
violation no this one wouldn't we said
twenty-five percent of our restaurants
have four or more critical violations
those are going to be fail and
everything else is going to be passed so
in that scenario we used some feature
selection like with random forest and
waited which features were most
important in determining that
classification know so we use the
ability that the estimators have to rank
features so for example the random
forest classifier you can output how
important the feature was in computing
the random forest and then get the top
10 features to then run through your
model this doing in a pipeline it's not
as transparent you don't know exactly
all the time you have to you have to
access it a lot differently so basically
this is just taking a model and saying
okay use this for your feature selection
and feed that into the new effort into
the estimator and make a prediction it
ended up with the scores i showed you
from this time that was actually just
using linear support vector machines
with no feature selection but if you you
kind of use this methodology you can
actually output just like a CSV at the
end that says I use this estimator I use
this for select remodel if anything and
then where those scores end up
well thank you and see you around